MARK MEADOWS TAKEN TO THE PODIUM
THERE.
A LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK, BUT
THEY ARE BACK NOW BUT I WANT TO
BRING ON DR. MARC SIEGEL FOR
ANALYSIS AS TO WHAT WE HEARD ONE
ABOUT THE FIRST HOUR AND A HALF
OR SO OF THAT HEARING.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> GOOD TO BE BACK WITH YOU.
>> Blake: I WANT TO WALK YOU
THROUGH A COUPLE HEADLINES AT
LEAST AS I SAW IT.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI SAYING THAT HE
IS "CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC" THAT
THEY WILL BE A VACCINE EITHER BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR OR AT THE
BEGINNING OF NEXT YEAR AND
WHENEVER THEY MIGHT BE A
VACCINE, HE SAYS IN 2021, THERE
WAS A "REASONABLE PERIOD OF
TIME" THAT WHOEVER WANTS TO GET
THE VACCINE WOULD BE ABLE TO
TAKE IT AT THAT POINT.
DR. FAUCI AND THE CDC DIRECTOR
ALSO SAYING THAT THEY BELIEVE IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT K-12 SCHOOLS
OR GRADES RESUME IN PERSON THIS
UPCOMING SCHOOL YEAR.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF WHAT WE’VE
HEARD SO FAR?
>> SO BOTH OF THOSE POINTS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT.
DR. FAUCI ON THE VACCINE MADE AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT POINT THAT’S
NEVER BEEN MADE PUBLICLY BEFORE.
HE COMPARED IT TO THE HIV
VACCINE AND SAID WITH
CORONAVIRUS, WE ARE SEEING THE
ANTIBODIES.
WE ARE SEEING WHAT YOU NEED, THE
NEUTRALIZING ANTIBODIES.
THAT’S THE REASON FOR HIS
OPTIMISM.
THERE’S A STRONG IMMUNE RESPONSE
ALREADY WHEN YOU WERE GETTING
OVER THIS VIRUS, AND YOU CAN
ALMOST FEEL HIS EXCITEMENT ABOUT
THESE VACCINE CANDIDATES.
SO THAT WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE.
HE IS ALSO SAID TO ME ABOUT
SCHOOLS REOPENING AND THE WORD
HE USED IS WHEN I’VE USED WHICH
IS THE DEFAULT SHOULD BE THAT
SCHOOLS REOPENING.
THERE’S TOO MUCH PUBLIC HEALTH
DAMAGE BY NOT CONSIDERING THAT
AND DR. FAUCI ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
TODAY, THAT THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
A HUGE PUBLIC HEALTH COST FOR
KEEPING THE SCHOOLS CLOSED AND
DR. REDFIELD SAID THAT AS WELL.
>> Blake: THEY BOTH DID, BUT I
WANT TO JUMP ON THAT FOR A
SECOND BECAUSE THEY TALKED ABOUT
K-12 SCHOOLS AND CREATES WHICH
IS IMPORTANT, BUT I CAN SAY THIS
SELFISHLY AS WELL THAT THERE’S A
LOT OF PARENTS IN THIS COUNTRY,
MILLIONS OF THEM WITH TWO,
THREE, AND 4-YEAR-OLDS AS WELL.
WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THOSE
CHILDREN?
>> THAT’S EVEN MORE OF A PROBLEM
BECAUSE AGAIN, THEY’RE SO MUCH
CARE THAT IS NEEDED AT HOME AND
THERE IS CARE WITH GOING TO
DAY CARE FACILITIES, AND WE
DON’T BELIEVE THAT VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE SPREADING THE VIRUS